what's going on guys this is Rob and a
couple of weeks ago we did an experiment
here on Cummings explained to see how
you guys would respond to the idea of us
just kind of making up our own what-if
stories on the channel and so we did a
story about what would happen if the
Hulk got a Red Lantern ring and the
feedback that I've got me from that is
insane you guys absolutely love that
idea like it's crazy how popular that
video is and so what this tells me is
that you guys want more what if stories
so since last time we had a Marvel
character getting a power that came from
the DC Universe today we're going to
switch it up and bestow a power from the
Marvel Universe on a DC character asking
the question what if the Venom symbiote
bonded with Batman now after that we're
going to do a little more
experimentation just a you know again
kind of see how you guys respond to it
last time we did a video explaining how
the Red Lantern Hulk would be defeated
and then we did a separate video
explaining how to kill the Red Lantern
Hulk this week we're going to roll them
together we're going to do a video we're
going to in this video we're going to do
a discussion on what would happen if
Batman became venom and then we're going
to answer the question of how we could
kill him which is going to be kind of
tough to do because we already did a
video on how to kill Batman but before
we get into that actual story we have to
go over what Batman what the Venom
symbiote would actually be able to do
now I'm not going to spend a whole lot
of time talking and going over Batman
he's Batman alright if you know anything
about comics if you're watching this
video if you wake up in the morning and
are still alive then you know who Batman
is Batman you'd have to leave the planet
Earth to find someone who wouldn't know
who Batman is and even then there's no
guarantee
I guarantee some alien race out there is
probably watching those old Adam West's
Batman episodes I can guarantee that's
happening he's a crime-fighting
vigilante
that's stupid rich and uses martial arts
prowess and endless supply of leading
edge technology to beat up bad guys
that's Batman what we really want to
focus on here is the Venom symbiote
because its history and abilities are a
bit more complicated so the Venom
symbiote is actually a member of an
alien race known as the Clint are that
is bonded with various hosts throughout
its history most notably Peter Parker
Eddie Brock and Flash Thompson now once
it bonds with an individual the symbiote
confers on that person a plethora of
power
foremost among these being superhuman
strength durability and stamina as well
as a regenerative healing factor that's
been shown to be powerful enough to heal
the host after being impaled or even
after having their head sliced into now
the symbiote also allows the host to
recall the memories of its previous host
and is also able to reproduce some of
their superhuman abilities so because
the symbiote has previously bonded with
spider-man subsequent house would be
able to crawl on walls just like
spider-man can and the host can also
shoot a webbing of sorts although it is
quite a little bit different from
spider-man's web slinging ability and
that the web's venom slings seems to be
part of the simian itself so if too many
webs are created the symbiote will
simply just be weakened until it can
replenish itself now the symbiote can
also mimic spider-man's spider-sense to
warn its hosts of impending danger and
can manipulate itself into camouflage
capable of disguising its host now of
course this is also compounded by the
fact that Eddie Brock actually trained
the symbiote to develop a set of
poisonous fangs capable of paralyzing
and possibly even killing its hosts
furthermore the symbiote can morph parts
of the hosts body into other objects for
instance after the symbiote bonded with
a man named Mac Gargan better known as
the spider-man villainous scorpion the
symbiote was able to create a tail in
order to mimic Mac Gargan scorpion
costume
similarly the symbiote can also increase
the size of its host which extends the
level of the hosts superhuman strength
even further beyond the 70 tonnes if
they can already lift at normal human
size while they're in possession of the
Venom symbiote so if Batman were to
become venom he would have access to all
of these powers in addition to his
amazing combat skills detective skills
an enormous arsenal of technology and
weaponry and here is how I think all of
it would go down so we open on a crash
site where an alien vessel has
crash-landed on earth I love doing these
things the site is surrounded by Argus
agents Advanced Research Group uniting
superhumans those you guys who don't
know they're basically a branch of the
government that works alongside
superheroes as well as the Justice
League members Batman and Superman now
of course everyone seems to be at a loss
however is a spaceship appears to have
simply been unmanned now while
discussing how unusual this is Batman
and Superman receive a call that their
services are needed elsewhere as there's
been a net
on ko City by Black Manta and King shark
I don't know for whatever reason they
have to go anyway the head of Argus
Amanda Waller tells them to leave and
deal with the problem and that she'll
contact him later if anything turns up
at the crash site and so they end up
leaving but by the time they arrive at
ko city they find the rest of the
Justice League has been able to defeat
and apprehend the villain so with
everything seemingly dealt with for the
time being and with the situation he
resolved and no word from Amanda
Waller's regarding the crash site
everybody just goes home so we pick up
the next day with Batman in the Batcave
where he remarks to Alfred that he still
hasn't heard any word of the strange
unmanned spacecraft so instead of just
sitting around and waiting he decides to
go on patrol and beat up some bad guys
to pass the time because you know that's
what you do when you're Batman so uh
since he's in Gotham it doesn't take him
long to run into some criminals trying
to rob a guy gunpoint
Batman beeps into action takes out one
of the crooks but one of the others
fires a shot at him now Batman clad as
usual in gorilla proof armor thinks
nothing of it he's been hit by bullets
before but he's shocked to see a stream
of black goo rise up to absorb the
bullet clearly Computers Batman
hesitates a moment and one of the other
thugs lunges at him with a knife the
black goo blocks his blow as well and
before long has engulfed Batman's entire
body empowered by the Soviet Batman
involuntarily starts laying waste to
every last one of these guys and before
long they're all laying at the ground at
his feet now as quickly as it had
covered him the symbiote receives
leaving Batman to survey the damage and
of course because it's a Batman comic
he's relieved to see the crooks are
badly beaten but they're not dead still
reeling from what has happened Batman
leaves their unconscious bodies for the
police and returns to the Batcave now
once back in the cave Batman runs a full
body scan on himself which picks up some
sort of foreign matter that the computer
cannot identify desperate to coax is
Cindy it back out he convinces Alfred to
fire a gun loaded with rubber bullets
added when Alfred fires the shot this
symbian emerges again just as expected
what Batman had not expected however was
to hear an unfamiliar voice at his head
asked why do you wish to harm us Bruce
Wayne a conversation between Batman and
the symbiote ensues with a Simeon
explaining that the two of them are now
bonded and have been since the Cindy at
first encountered Batman after his ship
had crashed
on the planet and that he can make that
man stronger than he could have ever
been on his own and can help him achieve
his goals of ridding Gotham City of
crime I can even help him do what he's
always been unable to do for years
finally stop the Joker for good now
Batman is faced with the decision of
either telling Waller and the rest of
the Justice League about the symbiote or
keeping it for himself and learning to
harness his strength to aid him in his
mission and because Batman is all about
keeping secrets from his allies he
naturally decides to keep the symbiote
for himself so for a while we see Batman
just like destroying criminals and
learning to use the symbiote in new ways
it becomes more effective than any armor
that he's ever had he's able to take out
his opponents from afar without even
needing to engage in hand-to-hand combat
with him and everything is simply going
amazing crimes down in Gotham he's able
to fight without it taking a huge toll
on him physically everything is pretty
cool up until it's not so naturally
Superman eventually finds out what's
going on and confronts Batman about it
Batman of course tells him to mind his
own damn business and that he's simply
doing what's best for his city and that
he is in full control Superman comments
that they don't know where the thing
came from
what is capable of or what its mission
is furthermore he's concerned about how
increasingly violent Batman is getting
Batman again tell Superman to shove off
and Navis idiot wants the same thing
that he wants to rid gotham city of
crime unconvinced Superman leaves warns
Batman that he'll be watching and vows
to figure out the origin and nature of
the symbian now everything comes to a
head following a mass breakout from like
Blackgate prison arkham asylum seemed a
little too extreme I kind of figured
like Blackgate prison would be a little
more reasonable but Batman arrives on
the scene and of course Flash's most of
the escaping prisoners would ease with
the help of the symbian until he comes
face-to-face with none other than Joe
Chill the man who murdered his parents
now Batman begins to feel rage
overcoming him which is not only coming
from his own psyche but is being
exacerbated by the symbiote and what
happens is that this rage keeps building
and building until Batman snaps and
actually kills Joe Chill so this is the
tipping point for pretty much everyone
Batman has been getting increasingly
violent in the way he deals with enemies
but
to this point he had never killed anyone
and so after this Batman begins to
spiral further and further out of
control kills more and more prisoners
and eventually that Justice League is
called to the scene interestingly
Superman is not there but there are two
additional members that have been called
in firestorm and black Canary now this
would seem odd to readers but it's
actually revealed in the story that
Superman is actually offworld seeking
out answers as to the origin of the ship
that crashed and the symbiote data
carried but in all honesty I mean we're
kind of making up the story right so I
mean let's be honest Superman could beat
up Batman
even with the Venom symbiote so Superman
coming in and just taking out Batman
does not make for a very interesting
story now as for why Black Canary and
firestorm are here we learn that
Superman had actually been contacted by
Alfred Pennyworth who had himself become
concerned with the direction that he saw
Bruce Wayne going in Alfred tells
Superman that he's watched the
experiments Bruce's run on the Symbian
and divulges that the Venom symbiote has
two observable weaknesses fire and sound
and so Superman puts in a call to
firestorm and black Canary to be on
standby should Batman go crazy when
they're needed which now is pretty much
basically when that's happened so what
we're going to have here is pretty much
complete chaos some of the Justice
League or assisting Gotham City Police
and trying to round up the escaping
prisoners and when I say some of the
Justice League I mean the ones who don't
matter and the rest are taking on the
venom control of Batman that's basically
on a killing spree however now that the
Justice League knows the symbiotes
weaknesses they're able to use black
Canary's ability to produce an
ultrasonic scream as well as fire storms
pyrokinesis to force the symbiote to
separate from Batman then of course they
would have to contain the symbiote as
well as get Batman out of the hands of
these prisoners before they can
basically kill him his weakened state
resulting from just having the symbiote
traumatically ripped away from his
physical body and then the story ends
with the symbian in containment bruce
wayne's is kind of moping around because
he allowed himself to cross a line that
he vowed never across yada yada yada
Superman's trying really hard to not say
like I told you so ah but we're
basically in a spot where like the day
is saved
you know Batman's defeated and that's
really the end of that but Rob core what
if we wanted to kill him what if we
wanted to kill Batman with the Venom
symbiote now by virtue of the ending of
the story
we know the Justice League's left that
not a lot and honestly it was really
just because of the fact that he's a
founding member he's considered to be an
ally by all of them and a friend to some
but say that we had a more nefarious
group one that wanted to actually kill
Batman how would they do it well as a
concept it's pretty simple the Venom
symbiote has very exploitable weaknesses
to fire and sound it gives its host
awesome abilities but it is by no means
invincible so any villain with like fire
abilities heat wave or d-list Batman
villain Firefly for example or ones that
use sound powers probably like an
effortless Superman villain silver
banshee would probably be able to cause
some serious damage to the symbian they
could probably get the symbiote to
separate from Batman and then we just
have to kill Bruce Wayne in his normal
form that of course is one of those
things that sounds easier than it
actually really is since no one has been
able to kill Batman yet with the
exception of Darkseid and he wasn't even
dead he was just time displaced and so
theoretically first one can be killed in
any conventional way which we discussed
at length when we did our video on how
to kill Batman and of course this is all
contingent on the venom eyes Batman not
killing these guys first which is
extremely likely so conceptually finding
a way to kill a venom eyes Batman it's
pretty easy but the practicality of
doing so would be a bit more challenging
but with that being said guys we are
going to bring this video to an end I
love this idea of combining like the how
to kill superheroes and the what-if
stories into the same thing I wouldn't
really say this one would be like the
standard because we've already killed
Batman
so I mean we'd really just be rehashing
what we'd already talked about I think
it might be a better idea to try with
something different maybe we should give
like give like Yoda the Speed Force no
we should give juggernaut the Speed
Force that's what we're going to do in
the next video we're giving juggernaut
speed force powers the juggernaut is
going to become the flash oh god it's
gonna be crazy
no we already did a video on how to kill
juggernaut you know we're going to do
we're going to do Darth Vader with a Red
Lantern ring yeah America we're going to
do Darth Vader with a Red Lantern ring
oh my god that's going to be insane
imagine that Darth Vader with a Red
Lantern ring Q that's gonna be
absolutely bonkers like he's going to
have this dude can you imagine that
imagine what that looks like Darth Vader
with like a Red Lantern ring that's like
glowing red and like a sift lightsaber
it'd be the most badass thing ever in
the history of anything that's ever
existed anyway guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end and I will catch you all later
priests today's video is brought to you
by Dollar Shave Club are you sick of
choosing between overpriced razors and
low quality plastic disposables or
Dollar Shave Club has your solution
their razors provide a high quality
close shave for the price of a
disposable dollarshaveclub.com delivers
amazing razors right to my door for a
fraction of the price that i used to pay
seriously I have no reason to deal with
the drugstore hassle and battle the
locked up razor fortress ever again and
neither will you
when you join the club just go to
dollarshaveclub.com polar slash comics
explain and get a 1 month membership of
any razor for 1 dollar
free shipping no commitments cancel
anytime with Dollar Shave Club you can
look smell and shave like a million
bucks without paying for it and here's
your chance to discover why millions and
millions of members like me love Dollar
Shave Club just go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash colors
explain and get a 1 month membership of
any razor for 1 dollar free shipping no
commitments cancel anytime
[Music]